[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is Kashif Khan he is
President and founder of the DNA company
I was put onto Kashif over a year ago
because I have breast implants and I
thought I was sick from him which I was
kaship was doing genetic pathway
research on why some women get so sick
from breast implants and so that's what
started the relationship I did his DNA
test which everybody is going to have
access to 15 off go to
thednacompany.com forward slash Danica
and you'll get 15 off super fascinating
test the portal itself that you get with
the information and your data is so easy
to use so I did that so I was able to
see what I do well what I don't do well
so in this interview we talked about
genetics and just what are they and
where did they come from and how do we
change them and telomeres and age region
how to reverse that and really like a
lot of it ends up boiling down to just
how do we be healthier Kashif himself
you here in the interview when he was 38
his biological age was 43 and now that
he's 43 his biological age is 33. really
really super smart guy he developed this
company in response to him being so sick
it comes from Passion I think you're
going to be able to feel that in this
interview he also has a book coming out
called the DNA way I just think this is
a must listen to interview and the DNA
test is a must-do test to really
understand yourself to live your best
life please hit subscribe and the bell
for notifications when we have an
episode come out and let me know your
thoughts in the comments element is a
tasty electrolyte drink with everything
you need and nothing you don't that
means that there's lots of salt and no
sugar element is formulated to help
anyone with their electrolyte needs and
is perfectly suited to any diet or
lifestyle for me I drink element all day
every day I put it in just about every
single drop of water that that I drink
for me it feels like it helps keep me
full it helps give me more energy and I
feel like water is absorbed better by
the body when it has element in it it
truly feels like magic to me receive a
free element sample pack with any order
when you use drinkelement.com
prettyintense that's drinkelement.com
pretty intense so good to see you yeah
you too I I just got off this other
recording where did Mindy Mindy tell you
about the summit that we're doing
together no when is it so we're
recording 40 interviews to have a female
Health event online event uh she's doing
10 of them I'm doing 30 of them and
we're putting it all together into one
massive this is what all women need to
know to be healthy type event online
holy schnikes yeah we just decided to
come together and do it so uh thanks to
you oh well you guys are both like two
of the most generous people in in
particular in the field of Health you
know you guys have both helped me so
much and that's an easy pairing you guys
are both awesome people no thank you
yeah so that's coming out uh we're
shooting and then August it's gonna go
live online can you give us a couple
highlights so one of the big things that
I'm seeing unfortunately is a lot of
crazy
rare and highly aggressive Cancers and
we we all know why right so uh I talked
to her about that a little bit she
didn't want to but she opened up and
she's really good with Cancers like she
breast cancer doesn't scare her all she
always fixes it that was a big one
because everyone I talked to and asked
the question they don't really think
about it they're like oh yeah wait now
that you say it there's a little too
much of this going on so there's no
immune system and you need an immune
system to constantly kill all the cancer
cells that are in your body and if you
don't have one they flourish and Thrive
and these things that are now be called
genetic cancers that are not genetic
cancers I can't tell you how many people
that are like in their 30s and 40s are
getting stage four terminal type
diagnosis what is the basis of cancer
what is happening that causes cancer
there's inflammation which is what we
talk about right inflammation is the
cells being unhealthy and essentially
losing their function and aging and
degrading there's degradation that
happens
but in order to so then that cell
becomes mutated becomes cancerous but
your body is constantly fighting that
with immunity right we think of immune
function as vitamin C and cold and flu
season but it's so much more your immune
system is fighting everything all the
time and when you trigger
immune suppression
from things that have been going on
then you don't have that front line
defense to constantly fight
the high levels of inflammation that
we're suffering from based on our
environment and our nutrition and our
stressors and our lack of sleep so
there's a double whammy of we have way
too much inflammation because of
everything that's going on and we lost
our immune systems that were at least
keeping it at Bay so then all sudden
things flourish that shouldn't exist why
does it mean why does inflammation make
such a difference like exp explain the
pathway to cancer through inflammation
inflammation is a necessary tool
inflammation was our ancestors used to
drop a hammer on their foot and they
would have an inflammatory response
which would repair repair that but it
would be a once in a while acute type
scenario going to battle get cut with
the sword body gets inflamed repair
repair when the stressors are constant
everything you breathe and everything
you eat and every relationship you have
is constantly you know over burdensome
then that thing that we have in us that
was designed to protect us becomes
chronic and constant and now the cells
which are constantly trying to repair
and they're head to toe you're in this
state of Crisis right and then there's a
domino effect of hormone response and
neurochemical response and all systems
start to fail 14 of the 15 top Killers
today are all rooted in inflammation so
this one thing inflammation is the
disease that causes cancer
cardiovascular disease diabetes
Alzheimer's etc etc the reason you get
inflammation is different but literally
if you pull out any CDC filing you'll
see that 14 the top 15 killers are of
inflammation and number three which is
the number one that's not one of the 14
is medical error doctors just making
mistakes
[Laughter]
number three cause of death in the U.S
is medical error today
it's heart disease cancer and Medicare
so if you get rid of inflammation
your chances of having the American
dream of left last 15 years have spent
in treatment sick in a bed which is the
typical average isn't almost
non-existent because most diseases can't
happen I want to understand it at more
of a granular level the energy of the
body is redirected in a way that it
shouldn't be some the cells are
suffocated they are losing cell
communication because of irregular
inflammation or how does it actually
form
these
growths and things like that a little
bit of all of that is happening right
and the the clinical explanation is
um sort of degradation right so the
cells are aging and so what is aging
aging is your DNA literally getting
damaged oxidized just like an apple that
gets Rusty right it's oxidation the
cells then physically manifest that your
skin starts to Sag your hair turns white
things are aging the things that we now
know which nobody paid attention to are
the things that you just said voltage
frequency oxygen levels none of these
things were treating
right these are the root root root
causes we are not aligned with what we
are wired for our our genetic makeup is
about a quarter million years old
right so who we are today is the same as
people from 250 000 years ago
our habits are about a hundred years old
in fact our the reality of today's
habits when you look at food and
environmental toxins is about 50 years
old so things really change in the 1970s
right but
if you take that and think about 250 000
years of habits that our body is now
expecting we are walking around in that
context and then fast forward to this
context which we are not genetically
evolved towards being in you know we
can't handle it so then yeah the
frequency and the voltage and the oxygen
and all the things you're mentioning we
don't expose ourselves to that you don't
wake up and walk on the grass you don't
get sunshine in the morning you don't
hear Rivers you don't hear birds
chirping right all of these things are
frequency all of these things affect you
at the cellular level so I as a
treatment will walk out my backyard down
into a Ravine and just go stand at the
river yeah I'll do that once a week
and I literally feel like I went into
sauna in terms of the mental health
relief yeah right so I know I did you
had asked a different question about
inflammation but I talking about all the
things that we don't consider are what
make us unhealthy Beyond just chemicals
and food Etc right we're really out of
our natural environment yeah when you
have a a any piece of equipment that's
wired to do a job and you force it down
another path
it's not gonna work
right we are all you know Ferraris that
are being treated as dump trucks
so we are wired to do a certain thing
but we're on we're on the wrong path
we're not designed for it can't cope
with it there are animals for example
that have the genetic ability to live in
hydraulic acid like they can live in
literally acidic environments because
genetically they're wired for that
mm-hmm
they'll thrive in that right there's
animals that can live underwater there's
it we know all this stuff but we are not
designed for the way we live that's why
we're so sick there's never been as much
chronic disease ever as there is today
do you think it's because
take it in a slightly different
direction do you think it's because it's
happening so quick right now or because
genetic adaptation does happen to some
degree
here's my belief from what I can see is
that animals and everything else around
us around us evolves
I have not seen evidence of that in
humans
you you and I have had these kinds of
conversations before but you know I was
really hoping my first question was
really going to be like what is a human
being because I wanted us to really drop
in to like slightly esoteric spaces sure
and then be able to extrapolate some
like more tangible things that are
happening in the here and now but you
know if we haven't seen true shifts in
genetics with human beings but you're
saying in animals there have been
there's a genome and there's an
epigenome genome is your code this is
the instruction manual that's in each
one of your cells that tells your cells
how to do their jobs different cells
read different parts of the manual so
the hard cell becomes a heart cell liver
cell becomes it read only reads that
page right so that's your innate code
your epigenome is those genes expressing
at different levels I might have a 8 out
of 10 hormone Gene but because of what I
ate or because of what I was exposed to
it's expressing at 6 out of ten or or
nine out of ten it got adjusted a little
bit so in animals what we're seeing is
that the actual genome the genetic code
changes in a giraffe's neck gets longer
and the ears get bigger and the wings
get wider and the animal changes over
time in humans what we're seeing is
there's a set for Mom and there's a set
from Dad
and I got two potential inputs and I
just keep winning this or losing this
Lottery because it keeps getting passed
down there's I can if there's uh A and A
B version I could get an a a a b b or a
b game just keeps getting passed down
but there's only two options A or B so
next Generation might be a bb or ba or a
a so they're getting bounced between
these options and it's cyclical that
they just coming back to AA and a b
right but the epigenome this is
something that we're seeing uniquely in
humans
is arming us
with
inheriting our ancestors experience an
amazing example of that is the Holocaust
where their science clearly showing
that the trauma that was experienced by
the people in it is now present in the
epigenome of the grandchildren of those
people
so they are sensitive to that
they're set they they are still
experiencing the trauma of what happened
at that time because their genes are
training them to be aware there was such
a significant impactful thing that
happened I'm gonna pass this code on to
the next Generation I'm not going to
change the genetics so they're not
evolving but I'm gonna pass this little
cheat code to them so that they can
support this problem that they might
have again you're saying that the base
genome does not change but the epigenome
does yeah yeah and then that may change
where two three generations in it's no
longer needed and it doesn't it goes
back to sort of default right and that's
kind of what we're seeing
um and it's but in animals we're seeing
Evolution it's clear there I haven't
seen evidence of it in humans We Are Who
We Are we we became who we are about a
quarter million years ago
that's a whole other conversation about
how we became who we are that is a good
conversation my focus on this channel
love to uh hear about the esoterics so
yes so essentially
it's hard to explain why at a time when
we think we are Peak technology now some
of us do right uh how is it possible
that technology that we do not have
access to seemed to have was implemented
on our genome a quarter million years
ago what happened there was a literal
Gene edit we understand Gene editing we
understand that it's possible to snip a
section and either remove it or replace
it we can't yet do it right the only
human approved Gene editing project that
I was ever done was on the i in humans
it was for some rare genetic condition
for the eye and it's local the
jurisdiction is here the eyeball right
so we don't yet know how to take your 50
trillion cells in your body insert and
edit and make sure every single cell
manifest that edit
a crispr is
so crispr the technology exists but we
haven't done it in humans
right it doesn't happen right meanwhile
it happened 250 000 years ago
yeah meanwhile we can't explain the
pyramids meanwhile yeah we can't explain
we can't explain go Beckley Tepe
meanwhile we can't explain a whole bunch
of things a whole bunch of things right
so 250 000 years ago there seems to be
an edit in the genome that made us who
we are what what does that mean that
there was primates
and then all of a sudden there was a
species with complex speech with a
larger brain with a bigger prefrontal
cortex and they were called humans and
when you say bigger skull there are all
of those for those who dive into ancient
history and see that there are skulls
that have been found that are yeah
elongated and much larger and indicative
of larger brains surely are have we
regressed what it looks like is the
genome became what it was at that time
and has just continued to be the same
now what we do with it keep in mind this
this thing that we walk in and is a
miraculous the current reality of how we
live is shutting off a lot of our
capacity you know a lot of people are
now experiencing a sort of evolution and
Consciousness and their ability to
connect in ways that they couldn't
before look at the past 250 000 years we
can't possibly believe that we are the
Pinnacle of that there's people that
maybe have achieved things in that level
or that world I should say in terms of
Consciousness is that we that we kind of
lost and we now are coming back to so if
you look at something like are the way
our genes and our cells
communicate with the environment around
us we are just starting to learn
but if you look at ancestral stories and
things that we know
oh all of a sudden that thing that
sounded like a fairy tale maybe it was
true and things like for example our
mitochondria we think of as a energy
source so your your body takes in oxygen
and nutrition to create energy and
that's done at the mitochondria and you
create this battery called ATP and you
can go use it whenever you need power
your mitochondria does a lot more than
that which we don't talk about
scientifically it's actually a
communication device it's constantly
trying to understand what's happening in
your environment so that each one of
your cells instantaneously is adjusting
to get you at the max or Optimal
Performance you need to be is there a
threat is there a smell is there a lack
of food like whatever is going on your
mitochondria is signaling from cell to
cell if I touch my forehead
instantaneously at each one of my 50
trillion cells knows that that happened
right and my mitochondria is creating
that communication we don't have any
technology that's capable of that so now
it also does that externally but what I
was the very first point was I think
we've lost some of that ability
right and we're now coming back to it
we're now understanding we are more than
just this thing that we're inside we
have a field around us that we're
connected to right were you saying that
it's not within our body that is that is
informing us that there is something
outside of our body that is helping in
that is creating some kind of heightened
communication
both for sending and receiving so what
we just talked about was receiving the
mitochondria is constantly looking out
for it's your defense system just
checking what's going on right and
communicating to yourselves so that your
body constantly responds appropriately
so you're safe
you also send signals out
now we're hearing a lot of talk about
manifesting and you know believing and
making how does your body actually do
that and it's funny because your fan
Kyra sent me a note saying that oh I
talked about something that we talked
about and she didn't fully explain it so
I'll fully explain it yeah this is
um
my raw interview if you haven't you
should she's a really special human
she's incredible her story is amazing
and yeah we just happen to sum up on
this conversation and she just said oh I
talked about this thing and you need to
remind me how it actually works so I'm
gonna remind you although so
your DNA is a code that tells your cells
what to do it is also a communication
device and this is known by the way by
the CIA who uses this technology but
it's nowhere in a scientific literature
right now there's offices in the CIA
where there's guys sitting that are
being told to visualize
a building that may be thousands of
miles away and draw a picture of what's
happening in that building so that the
Special Forces know how to enter the
building and
bomb something get a hostage back
whatever right so they're able to yeah
so the remote viewing right so now
that's the mitochondrial side which is
signaling and receiving now the the
sending out so your DNA
people have seen this image of this like
Spiral ladder right that's what your
genes look like the the point where the
rungs meet the sides are actual uh
that's your signaling device so it
actually happens at that point and what
happens
is your thoughts your beliefs we know
get sent out as frequency the actual
mechanism of that is through your genes
and I'm gonna at the end tell you why
this is so important so your genes in at
those specific points send out these
signals and by sending out those signals
you create your magnetic fields right
now the more you believe
and the more powerful that signal
becomes right and then that that weight
that you create in your magnetic field
creates the gravity that draws those
things towards you and that's how
manifest the actual physical mechanism
of how manifesting Works you're
literally creating weight in the
magnetic field just like a planet
creates weight on in the Universal field
which draws gravitational force towards
it you do that with you know whatever
you're putting out there so why now I
said I'm going to tell you why this is
so important that it happens at the DNA
because if you're not healthy you can't
do it
so what is health health is your cells
not being inflamed
right that's the its health is not
masking illness it's the not being sick
the state of having no illness that's
health so if you are eating the wrong
foods not taking care of yourself
exposed to chemicals over stressed under
sleep and your cells are inflamed and
your DNA is getting oxidized and damaged
you can't connect with the field and you
cannot put those thoughts out there
because the DNA is not functioning
properly right and this is why you'll
see the healthiest people are often the
most connected people because it's so
easy for them to do there's their their
body is you know Prime ready to put
those signals out there I mean I've even
noticed the reason why we connected in
the first place was
um on breast implants and how you were
doing all the research on the connection
between genetics and the pathways that
make breast implant illness a reality
for some people the implants were
creating so much inflammation
because my body was fighting so hard
that even you know I've noticed just my
body continuing it's been a year now and
um a year
tomorrow oh wow and
um and uh I remember and my body has
been continuing to reduce inflammation
and like one of the ways that it's been
noticeable is just how much easier it is
to get a vein like I still do so much
work and so like for a while after my
surgery and even before it was so hard
to get a vein and now that my
inflammation is gone
my veins have like been able to relax
and expand and they accept the catheter
so much easier so and many many other
things but that's just one of them I was
just talking about with a friend and
because I was in um Costa Rica with Dave
doing stem cells and plasmapheresis and
um and so you know they gotta they got a
vein
five out of six out of seven times one
time they didn't but um but all of them
they did and they were using pretty big
gauges especially for
plasmapheresis but you know inflammation
yes is just it just it just seems like
and also the hormonal side like how does
it affect the hormonal side so
aggressively
yeah so you're it's more the opposite
your hormones are so women have a whole
other set of problem that men typically
don't have to deal with which is
estrogen toxicity and I would say when
it when it came to the research that we
did genetically so what did we do the
what was what genes do was already
understood we didn't invent genetics
what we did was we said how do we take
this amazing science and apply it to the
big problems we have cardiovascular
disease diabetes it wasn't doing that
yet if it wasn't a rare genetic
condition wasn't much to do with this
tool so we did that by spending three
years with seven thousand people one by
one by one fixing each one of their
problems to get to their why like if I
can't truly solve your problem I haven't
used genetics properly it should be
personalized for you right and when we
did that
the biggest area that needed the most
help was female hormone health so that's
the area that the Delta value between
here's how bad it is and how good it
could be huge gap and every woman was
kind of told well you're a woman you're
supposed to have these problems it's
hormones right that you're supposed to
have a crazy menopause and infertility
and PCOS and all these problems which no
you don't have to have if you understood
the genetics of the hormone Cascade and
what's that thing that makes it more
difficult for women is there something
called estrogen toxicity so
when you make your hormones on a monthly
basis progesterone becomes testosterone
becomes estrogen and in that Cascade you
can do those at different rates and
speeds so fill different buckets at
different levels and once you finally
fill the estrogen bucket you then have
three options two four or 16
hydroxyestrogen two is the good clean
stuff you want 4 and 16 are toxic 16
being more toxic than four and a lot of
the women we're seeing that are coming
to us saying I have fibromyalgia I have
infertility issues endometriosis crazy
migraines mood issues they're making
these two metabolites now why is this a
problem of today's generation because
the genome alone is not enough the
genome is here's how your body works
here's the red flag let's prioritize
this now we need to understand your
epigenetic habits what is your
environment what is your nutrition what
is your lifestyle and the pairing of
those two is your net result
and the reality is that today the
hormone disrupting threats are so
prolific
that there's so many more problems so
the women that were estrogen toxic in
Grandma's generation didn't get sick
they were truck they were toxic it
caused some inflammation but the body
can handle some inflammation now the
total load is so much that it's causing
all these issues including breast cancer
and this was a big thing we learned and
we can now deal with that root cause and
make sure that women don't get sick got
it so there are so many things in our
environment like Plastics and food and
um the air that we breathe from all of
the chemicals being sprayed in the air
to EMF disrupting frequency
all of those things they but especially
the consumables like drinking out of
plastic and the stuff in our food that
is estrogen that creates more estrogen
yeah it's your body treats it as if it's
additional estrogen right so it did
that's why it's called estrogen mimic so
it mimic accessories so it's not
actually estrogen when it enters your
body your body can get confused thinks
it's estrogen so genes turn on to
convert it into that estrogen byproduct
which is toxic and inflammatory is it
yes is it also kind of uh does it make
because estrogen is such a female
hormone does it is it kind of amping
that up like making more female like I
think about female like having curvier
bodies or like just like does it
continue to does it make you more woman
too so that's what's happening to men so
that's kind of what I was gonna ask next
is that yesterday is this something
that's happening to men and is this why
perhaps we're seeing
um more shifting with men to women
whether it's through transitioning does
it shift men and more into
so there's some that same Cascade that I
said progesterone becomes testosterone
comes men do the exact same thing we
just do it daily men have men have a
daily cycle women have a monthly cycle
same exact cycle and men are more likely
to be more androgenized more
testosterone women are more likely to be
more exercised so now the answer to that
question isn't a blanket answer it
depends on what your hormones look like
so someone like you who's more
androgenized more chiseled features
petite frame right that's more
testosterone so that's going to drive
you from androgenized to call it what
the typical estrogenized woman would
have been right now a woman who's
already estrogen dominant is now going
to not maybe get more curvier figures
but she's going to start to get some of
the um conditions like fibrom
fibromyalgia endometriosis you know
crazy migraines mood issues because
she's overestrogenized and if she's also
toxic too much inflammation what we're
seeing with the men
um
the I guess the the change in culture
and the femininity amount around among
men yeah there's no surprise when you're
taking what used to be a manly man you
know and you're removing all of what
creates testosterone the fight the Vigor
the the training the exercise and your
sedentary and so there's a funny thing
with hormones
when you sort of lean forward and fight
that calls on your body to create more
testosterone
when you create some more testosterone
it calls on your body to lean forward
and fight and you get on this vicious
cycle forward
right same is true the backwards the
opposite I should say if you kind of
lean back you're like I'm not going to
do it you get more estrogenized the the
warrior versus The Warrior
right and so we all now have a warrior
lifestyle sit in a chair and type right
and be afraid of everything everything
is a problem then don't train don't
fight don't do anything Politically
Incorrect you know tone yourself down
and so we're all going into this Warrior
mode which is also an estrogen problem
all of us right so uh the men that are
out there saying let's do something and
rile ourselves up and become men there's
something to be said there in terms of
not losing half of our gender right
what's the solution
well the solution it's it depends I mean
if if it's like is it a pill yeah
there's pills or is it a culture shift
yeah that's probably necessary also you
know we're there's some things we're
trying to fix right there's some which
need to be fixed inclusion yes let's fix
inclusion because there's some people I
have had two business partners uh in the
last few years that are both gay right
and they need to be included and not be
discriminated against right right and
but the but what is also true is a
person who does isn't innately you know
uh by choice or by birth but more by
influence of chemicals and hormones and
you know confusion
unnatural right that was not their who
they naturally are right right so you're
you're taking away the identity of
someone who actually is something and
then lending it to somebody to create
confusion uh and a lot of that has to do
with hormone disruption we're seeing it
over and over and over and over and over
again so the to answer your question
the chemicals are disruptive the birth
control is disruptive the Teflon coated
frying pans are disrupted the Plastics
are disrupted so understand that
ancestral habits are the healthiest
habits that's what we are still wired
for our bodies have not caught up
genetically to cope with all of that
Plastics don't clear your body they
cause cancer and they just float around
forever right forever chemicals don't
leave it was about a month ago I read
this article about Lululemon pants being
loaded with uh fluorine which is a
forever chemical which just doesn't
leave you know and it's very
specifically in the crotch lining which
is when you're sweating with an opening
taking in the fluorine you know yeah
amazing right so um just understanding
so to answer your question understanding
how prolific hormone disruption is in
your environment in your food and
everything you do from the chemicals
you're spraying on your tabletop to the
pesticides in your lawn what is hormone
disruptive what is not understand that
second is
it's so prolific that it may even be
hard to manage even then so you may
decide that hormone treatment is
beneficial for you right you may still
want to be the manly man or the womanly
woman and you may want to take hormones
because our reality again is not
Grandma's reality our genes are their
genes but our context is different we're
in a different bucket with different
problems that we are not designed for so
we need more intervention
we need more supplementation or whether
it's hormones or even just things like
dim that slow down the estrogen pathway
simple supplement it's a broccoli
extract right so it's a combination of
these two things understanding the
threats eliminating them understanding
what you can do to add in supplement to
turn the dial up on your capacity to be
that person you were supposed to be what
about like
the this area that scares me the most
right now which is our food and you know
the the the the scare of
mRNA being added into
animals and foods for our consumption
like what the hell's going on that now
does that edit now is that going to go
more towards again our sort of
biological nature is this meant affect
our genetics
so let me tell you a story
right now in the state of Missouri
there's a bill that's trying to be
passed I think it's Bill 1169
that says that
foods that have mRNA technology in them
need labeling to warn people that this
may alter your genome
and the current state is there's a lot
of pushback by big food and big Pharma
why is there pushback if there's no
problem
so since 2018 so mRNA we know of it post
covet right we think it's a brand new
thing that landed in 2020
mRNA for pigs started developing in
2012.
it's been used in pork since 2018. yeah
the pork you've been eating since 2018
has mRNA technology in it that's not a
secret yeah it's made by moderna and
Merck great and and now yeah and now
here's the really wonderful part of the
story is the way it was designed is
there's a baseline product which is
called the delivery method and because
it's mRNA and it's custom they respond
to each unique virus by creating this
custom portion that then gets injected
into that flock of pigs right that's
custom portion which is the active
portion has no requirement for safety
check from FDA no because this yeah
because this thing is approved this
Baseline was approved went through all
the vigorous whatever is required the
it's a custom product so how can we
possibly approve a custom product we
have to immediately respond to whatever
the new virus is so this thing does not
require approval and this is why the
state of Missouri who's trying to
prevent which is you know such a big
part of their
um
sort of their ecosystem farming and
agriculture they're saying no we don't
understand what this does yet and you
can't prove to us that it doesn't do
what we're worried that it does
please put a label that's all we're
saying in this bill to warn people and
there's major major pushback why is
there pushback because the what is the
label claim this may alter your Human
Genome so if you have a signal an mRNA
signal that's designed to edit something
how do we know it doesn't stop at the
animal that was injected in
if you're eating it well why are they
injecting the animal in the first place
other than to give it to us is there a
reason well it's it's meant to be like
antiviral so you know protecting so
their vaccines have been used in animals
for some antibiotics right so they're
just saying here's a better way to do it
it's custom for the actual strain and
that local Farm or area uh yeah I don't
get it it doesn't add up you know
there's right now there's over 100
million wild animals that are being
injected with mRNA
to basically just infect the planet
because if they're wild they're gonna
okay so yeah and let me just like check
and balance this real quick because you
said that we haven't had our genes
really changed since 250 000 years ago
so is this on an epigenetic level that
we're being
alter or is this a baseline genetic
thing so the scary thing is we don't
know
we don't really know what this stuff
does uh but what we do know is crispr
technology exists
and what we do know at the you know uh
biotech level me being in the Biotech
Industry is it's not it's not ready for
me to develop a product yet right I I
have tried to make products like for
example I know that I can prevent
cardiovascular disease if I can alter
the 9p21 gene which gives you a more
robust endothelial lining the arterial
walls if I make your arterial walls
stainless steel you're not getting
cardiovascular disease because remember
I have terrible veins
quality genetic veins
so you know you get a trade-off you got
yeah you get a little bit of a good
little bit of bad so what I'm trying to
do is fix the bed which is if I can make
a crispr technology product Gene editing
gene therapy then great I can fix that
problem so I'm being told right now I
can't do that meanwhile
um we don't know who has access to what
right the the in theory crispr works so
is it that it's not yet available or is
it just not yet available to me
right so that's the fear we don't know
what it does yet and and what we the the
fear is that it does edit your genome
what is the edit what are what's trying
to be edited I don't know you know we
really don't know yet um but the the
usage and the the like why are 100
million wild animals being injected in
our American forest for what purpose
like I I don't get it I don't
understandable
um I don't know I just yeah we're just
like worldwide vaccination worldwide I
don't think something to be said about
shedding which is not
um proven here or this way or that way
but I can tell you that I work with
practitioners uh that are not vaccinated
that in Toronto there's a lot of where I
am in Toronto there's a lot of NHL
hockey training I work with a lot of the
doctors that work with the hockey
players and I know some of them who are
never been vaccinated that had extreme
vaccine injury from working with the
hockey players who had just been
vaccinated which means that they were
shedded on right so the extent and the
whys behind all this stuff we don't
really know but we do know that it's in
our pigs and it's soon going to be in
our chickens and they're really fighting
to make sure it doesn't get in our beef
uh but it looks like we're going in that
direction the worst thing is the plants
by the way it the easiest way to
transmit is through plants much easier
than animals the technology already
exists it's already been going on so and
it's so that's the thing where it's just
so easy to do you know it's it's in
everything it's at all is that because
it goes into the soil and spreads and is
that because of the wind and blowing
seeds around I mean what what is it why
is it no the the technology to get it
into plants is just much simpler it's
just a very it's already happening it's
a very easy thing to do yeah it's a very
simple easy way to go about and it's
already happening what about stem cells
stem cells and peptides I'm really
curious about what they're doing so
peptides are call it somewhere in
between a supplement and a drug
right that's a that's a peptide so it's
not quite supplementing it's not food
and it's also not as potent and
condensed as a drug it's something in
the middle
right and so if you're going Beyond
here's my mitochondrial supplement or my
vitamin C and you want to be more
aggressive on a very specific biological
pathway there's typically a peptide for
every biological Pathways you can focus
on I can't sleep my hormones are screwed
up you know I get numbness in my fingers
whatever there's some there's a peptide
to fix everything stem cells are the
only cell that can become any other cell
they're regenerative so what does
regenerative mean we every day are
losing and making three to four million
cells in our body every day right and we
become a new version of ourselves every
once in a while this person you see here
didn't exist a year ago that is all
brand new material right so stem cells
can go do that for you and so
regeneration means damaged tissue uh
inflammation inflamed tissue
inflammation right so anything that is
breaking down wear and tear
um I have for example sample a shoulder
injury and I saw under an ultrasound the
actual muscle tear right so that's a
perfect example of put some stem cells
in there and it will just regenerate and
repair the tissue because stem cells can
become any kind of tissue and they go
around trying to fix things that's what
they do
so there's other Technologies like that
coming I think I hinted to you about a
gene therapy that we're trying to work
on right now there's a gene called
Foxhole 3 that we test for and Foxhole 3
is a superhuman Gene where this process
where I talked about where your body is
eliminating cells and creating new cells
all the time getting rid of mutated
dying cells and making good fresh ones
uh foxho3 if you have a certain version
of it allows you to do that at like a
hyper efficient Pace right so you become
it's the person that's like 80 years old
riding their bike that looks like
they're 50. I want to be that girl so
now that's why I want to make this gene
therapy so I can turn that's a very
healthy way to use this technology if we
know this Gene allows us to do that and
if I can create a gene therapy that
gives you the efficient version of that
Gene you can now innately do that and it
lasts like two to three years and you
keep redoing it redoing it so there's
amazing stuff coming down the pipeline
in terms of Biotech so do we know
because I did your DNA test
um
do we know do you know through that
testing if I have that Gene or not
I do you do yeah oh my god let's find
out I can literally check right now as
we go oh my God that's so fun so for
while you're while you're looking that
up um we'll get into this next because
this is fascinating and I feel like I
don't think there's a single human being
that wouldn't want to I don't think that
anyone would not want to know
um but Kashif developed a DNA test that
tests for and I'm gonna have you go
through basically the basic sort of
buckets that you test for like
um neurological and hormonal and all of
those things for for what you are
looking for
um and so I was able to learn so much
from Kashif about just you know certain
supplementation based on my genetics and
um what I need what again like you said
fix what's wrong so that you can live
better and longer
um and so that's why I knew that little
tidbit about my veins being a very low
quality uh genetically I have very low
quality vein walls while the wall the
wall or the vein itself but we found out
that I have the highest amount of
dopamine receptors so yeah and then we
were also looking for the breast implant
illness Pathways as well which include
the endocrine system with the hormones
and how I you know how much hormone
comes in if I if I clear that hormone or
not
um as well as various other things so
um after you tell me if I'm superhuman
or not then we can get to uh the test
itself because I just think everyone
should do this so we need to edit in a
drum roll
and there it is you have one copy of the
Superhuman Gene okay cool yeah so either
mom or dad gave it to you okay either
one of them gave the normal which is
still excellent which means that
um and we can see it I mean looking at
you you have this youthfulness around
you right so it just means you're going
to age a little slower
than a typical person so it doesn't mean
you go abuse yourself and you know but
it does mean that you're you're you know
it just your cells are going to be
healthier and younger for longer you you
stay ahead of that I'm aging process so
you can have two maximum is you can have
both of them from the mom and the dad
and I got one yeah so here's the pace
that humans are supposed to do it you're
doing it like 30 better and then if you
have two copies it's like 50 60 better
oh my gosh that's the is that awesome I
mean that's cool
um all right
all right test because I think it's
fascinating yeah so really what we've
understood is that first of all
this was developed because I was sick
and I don't come from the industry right
so I I was in the then the marketing and
PR business I used to help startup
companies grow it's what I love doing
taking an idea making it into something
helping that team exit their company and
then move on to the next one now you're
doing it for yourself yeah now I'm doing
it for myself because I found something
that felt like my legacy it felt like
this is so impactful first of all I
healed my whole family then I started
healing my friends then I started
healing people that were calling in like
this is really important so what
happened I had
eczema psoriasis eczema was so bad by
the way that I couldn't open my left eye
it was like sealed shut my psoriasis was
so bad that my Knuckles when I would
clasped like this they would bleed I had
gut issues uh depression because my
dopamine is the exact opposite of of
yours right uh and I had migraines that
was the worst part I used to literally
couldn't function horrible horrible
intense migraines I used to vomit from
the pain that's how bad it was so
yeah yeah so now and you've of course
loaded with the bii also you know that
makes it even worse right yeah so holy
totally ketchup totally it was when
I had my implants that I was getting
migraines yeah inflammation and I would
I was racing still and I thought it was
um I thought maybe I was getting carbon
monoxide poisoning and that wasn't it I
was checking everything and basically
like I think my just my load was so high
that it was so easy to tip it over into
bigger expressions like a migraine like
I could have sometimes it happened just
on its own but usually if I if I had one
drink of alcohol on Sunday night after a
race guaranteed two-day two-day migraine
which did one time end up in me throwing
out yeah so because what's happening is
your body can handle inflammation yeah
here's your inflammation bucket but
because of your implants you were
already full
right so you just needed one thing to
push you over the edge and you were just
constantly teetering at this full line
because of the the blow that
inflammation load so anyways I kind of
experienced the same thing one of the
big discoveries for me was when it comes
to detox of the gut there's a gene
called gstm1 I don't even have it
completely missing from my genetic code
so when you're eating pesticides
chemicals all this stuff it goes
directly into my bloodstream causes
crazy inflammation which is why I had
the eczema and the migraines right I
also uh when it comes to hormones I make
a lot of toxic testosterone so I make a
lot of testosterone which is great but I
wasn't working out properly like I used
to when I was young and so this toxic
byproduct called dihydrotestosterone
which is actually a potent version if
you use it properly if you train uh was
also causing me inflammation there was a
number of other things so
I healed myself I got my arthritic
mother out of bed who literally was
bedridden she now goes to the gym and
trains you know and drives around her
car does her own groceries so started to
heal and I realized medicine is broken
because when I was going to the doctor
you know five different problems taking
five different pills from five different
doctors the the real aha moment for me
was when I was asking why did this
happen
right there must be something all these
things just happened all at the same
time at this age I was 38 at the time
why did I eat something wrong and I
understood that that wasn't in their
toolkit they didn't they didn't even
figure out why for forget about giving
me an explanation it's like that's not
what they do so I did it myself and I
and I figured it out and I figured out
through my genome that there's certain
jobs my body just doesn't do which is
why I got so sick which is why my mother
couldn't get out of bed which is my my
niece ran away from home with anxiety
issues and is now flourishing as a
straight A student she would have been
on anxiety pills if I didn't understand
genetically what was going on with her
right which is why my best friend at the
time had a cholesterol problem that he
couldn't understand even though he was a
pharmacist he couldn't deal with it
which we then got rid he's no longer on
medication right so we started to learn
and fix and from there uh we built a
panel Dave was actually very helpful
there
he helped in terms of the solution side
so I now know how the body works and I
know I know what to tell you to do you
need to focus on this system whether
it's your hormones whether it's your
brain whether it's whatever and go
support it Dave then helped me with what
do we do about it what is the right
supplement what is the right activity
what is the right oxygen treatment Etc
and that's now built into the reports
then we went into uh well how do we
actually get people to do things because
I can't talk to everyone our scientists
and clinicians can't talk to everyone so
we went to a gentleman named Dr B.J Fogg
who wrote a book called tiny habits so
he right he runs the Stanford University
behavioral change lab so he's a guru
when it comes to behavior change and we
said here's our reports here's all the
recommendations go make people do it so
now he built the behavioral change
components right into the reports so
it's very easy to learn and Implement
and change and we now you know whether
it's I can't sleep at night whether it's
I have mood issues burnout
procrastination addiction whether it's I
don't feel well as a woman you know I
have hormone issues infertility Etc
whether it's why is it every time
there's a common cold I'm the only one
in the house that just can't get through
it you know my immune system is shocked
why do I have cancer yeah why me right
we I did exactly what my sister did why
did I get it right
um and then it's diet nutrition should I
be keto should I be vegan I can't tell
you how many vegans we'd have to tell
them this is why you're sick and with
empirical evidence because the genes
that create the enzymes to break down
the lentils and beans and all your key
protein sources they just don't make the
genes that drive them we can see are
broken right
um so everything about diet Nutrition
Fitness Etc so how does this thing work
right what jobs does my body do well so
I can I know I don't need to do anything
about that what jobs does my body not do
well and now what could that lead to all
these prongs of symptoms that I
complained about the symptoms aren't the
problem it's a system failure if I deal
with that all the symptoms go away and
that's what we've kind of figured out
yeah yeah the portal is so easy to use
um obviously I'm fortunate to know you
you can read my report for me but um but
the but the portal itself that you've
created with the
um the categories of testing of genetic
testing and Pathways and
um that it is so easy to click on and
use and see what you need to do see what
you're good at see what you're bad at
um and then is there still a separate
sort of report that can be sent to a
doctor that's a more detailed ex
um a more detailed and and higher volume
amount of calls to action that your
doctor can look at because that was one
part of it too yeah so one Challenge on
our end is we know a lot more than
what's in the report but we aren't
allowed to say it because of regulatory
issues so just yeah yeah well I mean I
can't tell you that I see breast cancer
coming even though I see breast cancer
coming because that's diagnostic right
so yeah but I can tell you that your
estrogen dominant and estrogen toxic and
then teach you what that means and then
you can use that tool in all of your
problems right so that's one thing about
your DNA is that it's not a one-time
blood pressure or cholesterol it number
it's a here's my instruction manual I go
back to it for every decision I have to
make I go from puberty age to fertility
age to menopause age those are three
very different phases where I have to
make different decisions I go back and
reinterpret for that context right I can
still go back to this thing because my
DNA doesn't change so yes so so now to
answer your question so there is a
clinician report which does have more
recommendations more clinical language
that we can't directly to say to
Consumers so click a button goes to your
practitioner and then they can then if
you want to dive deeper we also have
practitioners that are trained to do
this so if you want our coaches to do
things they can but if you have a coach
you would like like working with yeah
just push the button and it sends them a
clinical report where where is the
future of regenerative and preventative
medicine going like what framework do
you see because I feel like you're on
the Leading Edge of personalized
medicine so where is it going I see the
the the current conflict we have
continuing
in a different Battlefield which is
right now we have medicine which is go
do whatever you want and when you break
yourself the doctor will fix you right
that's medicine right versus functional
medicine which is let's understand why
disease happens and make sure you never
get sick so two very different ways to
think about your health both exist today
it's your choice which one you do why
people fall in the other bucket is
because the financial structure the
incentives behind what does my insurance
actually cover and pay for are all in
the first bucket of weight to get sick
and mask it because the insurance
companies and Pharma they're all
intertwined it's all the same thing so
this you have to pay out of pocket but
what better thing to pay for than your
health right so that same thing is now
happening in regenerative and the future
of medicine and here's a perfect example
you've probably seen this gentleman uh
who's saying that he reversed his age 10
years and he spent two million dollars
on himself have you seen him uh he kind
of looks like an L from Lord of the
Rings is the best way to understand what
David Sinclair are we not David Sinclair
no a younger guy uh I'll get you his
name but anyway most people would have
heard of him just recently he's been on
different podcasts in the media talking
about he reversed his age biologically
about 10 years and by the way everybody
can do the same I've done the same I can
teach you how easy that is when I
started this journey I was 38 and my
biological age was 43 because I was
pretty sick I am now 43 and my
biological age is 33.
okay
holy yeah and I've been and it's
been 33 for the last two years
right so it's been kind of staying there
so and this is measuring epigenetic
expression the thing we talked about
measuring uh aortic stiffness so
cardiovascular age you can do a Doppler
scan on your arteries to understand how
much plaque there is so there's a way to
determine biological age and I've been
able to reverse and maintain that for a
little while so and it didn't cost me
the two million dollars that this guy's
talking about so now the how now the
thing that I was saying that the current
conflict is now being translated into
this future of medicine what he's saying
is if you spend two million dollars with
me I will reverse your age
right and he's building an industry all
that which is great but he's doing it in
a way that is reactive
right it's like you go do whatever you
want I'm not going to change your diet
I'm not going to I have all these tools
and tricks and technology that are gonna
bring your age down but then you're
gonna go right back to your habits
and you're still going to be inflamed
and you're still going to have bad mood
issues and your gut and your brain are
still connected and when you eat wrong
you're still going to have a bad day in
the brain right so all these things if
you don't heal and so the path that I
choose to take is to slowly adopt better
habits yeah yeah and not to do it all in
one day yeah and to every day add a new
thing and add a new thing and add a new
thing and eventually you become
from I'm trying to get better to I go to
the gym to I'm in health Enthusiast to
health is my hobby to I'm a biohacker
yeah right to how do I live to 150
right okay maybe Dave wants 150 I think
Dave wants 180. I'm calling 120. I'm
good with 120.
um so finish your thought and then I
want to talk about telomeres yeah so
there's plenty of science to say to
support what you're saying that 120 is
the age right our bodies are designed to
live to that age and I think our
ancestors used to until we got so sick
we stopped living that long right these
phases of learn all the red flags
whether it's through your genetics or
through your gut microbiome learn the
things that your body is failing at
because that's going to be the
foundation of what causes your
accelerated aging or your disease the
two things you don't want and you don't
have to have by the way then you start
to understand what do I do what are the
habits how specifically do I need to eat
is keto the right choice for Me Maybe
it's not right maybe I cycle on and off
of Carnival which by the way is the
right choice for me I can't stick to
keto I'll get sick but when I do it for
a few weeks I feel amazing I need to
cycle on and off right so what are the
right choices you start to adopt those
habits and you start to become that
Health Enthusiast this becomes a
priority right and then yeah yeah yeah I
do you start to understand that every
choice you make is either a step towards
health or a step away from Health every
single choice you make in everything you
do right and when you get to that point
then you're the biohacker that's when
you start looking at things like stem
cells and oxygen because if you haven't
got the terrain ready
right if you haven't spent the year or
two to optimize the terrain you're
putting stem cells into a body where
you're not going to benefit from it yeah
yeah there's benefit I'm not going to
say zero but you're spending twenty
thirty thousand dollars in a treatment
to get 20 of what you could have got a
hundred
yeah right yeah I mean even for me when
I went and did stem cells just a couple
weeks ago
um they recommended based on the fact
that I have mold and metals and various
different things still I'm getting rid
of
um that it's better to harvest my
um stem cells do a stem cell Harvest
um next time like get the stem cells so
I got stem cells intravenously
um and then next time my body is a
little bit more right healthier it's a
little bit in better shape to Once want
to keep those so actually essentially me
being older will be better because I'll
have less inflammation I will have
healthier cells I will be in a better
condition so essentially I'm probably
going to be younger next year and that's
a better point in time to take my stem
cells to then use to regenerate to give
to me over and over again so I'll have
like 41 or 42 year old stem cells then
forever after that yeah so you're
let's go a little esoteric
sure you have to barely did at the
beginning I thought we were going to go
all the way down the path of
extraterrestrial intervention
um but telomeres so is it true so you
were talking about obviously 250 years a
thousand years ago is when we have a
gene splice edit something what seemed
what I've heard is sort of unexplainable
we don't understand why there is a
splice in the in the genetic coding
um and that uh that telomeres
are capped and is that something that's
outside that seems that appears to have
been done to us and then also is it true
that they're capped for us to live to
120 years only
up until literally a couple years ago
the only uh thinking around telomeres
was here's your DNA right and remember
at the very beginning I was saying your
DNA getting damaged is a definition of
Aging that's that's what it is your
cells unravel your DNA gets damage and
you age so the telomeres are like
bumpers so they protect your DNA and so
telomeres have been a a marker for
biological age because the more worn
down they are Yeah the more you've
abused your DNA and that's how old you
actually are biologically right
but this is based on these various
algorithms and clocks that assume we can
get to 120. so if you look at our innate
biological function and structure we are
beings that are designed to live to 120
and those telometers mirrors are meant
to last until that age oh there's
there's two things why is there a cap
is is it is it to protect us which we
think it is or is it to cap us
which one which one is it because isn't
there stories in ancient history Bible
even where people live for several
hundred six seven eight hundred years
yeah every ancient tradition talks about
people living for centuries
right and we're seeing evidence of that
dummy you've spoken to plenty of people
that have evidence of that so what
happened is it that we have something
that we evolved into to protect our DNA
or since there was a magic edit was
there also a magic cap installed to
limit how how old are the how many years
our DNA can actually last so we in
science we're reacting to everything so
we found this thing and we say no it's a
bumper It's a protector and if we
measure it we know how old we are but if
we dig deeper and we start to look at
what we've learned historically there's
plenty of content that's not from 2023
that was from you know minus 20 to 250
000 right that tells us otherwise that
people did live longer
um and it's it's not it's too
coincidental that different people in
different parts of the world that never
spoke to each other all say the same
thing
right that doesn't make any sense so uh
and it's not that we just live longer
they're very specific about the like six
to eight hundred years thing and they're
from different parts of the world at
different times up until recent history
the recent recorded history which is
what you learn in school is when this
ends the story ends kind of post Christ
type history right everything be before
that is a blur to us it's not a blur if
you look at ancient texts that are
available
we just aren't taught it right and it's
a very different story if you look at
stuff so it's a question mark is this
telomere protective or is it a cap it
seems like it's both could those stories
of Ben
off Planet extraterrestrial or hybrid
beings that did live six eight hundred
years but we this we as a homo sapien
sapien or whatever we are
um human being we only have ever lived a
certain amount of time which seems to be
much shorter is that that could be
possible too so if there was a
technology a quarter million years ago
that took a primate and edited two parts
of the genome
to make us who we are
somebody with some intelligence had to
do that and it wasn't us
exactly right it
that was not Evolution Evolution doesn't
happen in an edit it takes millions of
years
since that time we have not seen
evolution in ourselves
right so how did that happen overnight
that was a cause that was that was
intentional so I don't know if the
answer is
the Lord came down and edited us right
and created us is the answer that
there's another species from another
planet or from this planet that maybe is
still here somewhere that we don't know
about right so what but what's clear is
that the way we became Who We Are
was not the way every other species
became who they are it was not we didn't
not evolve into it we became it there
was a switch that was turned on that was
immediate and that was two edits to diff
two different parts of our genome that
are clear that no scientists can dispute
exist they just don't want to talk about
why it happened nobody's trying to
investigate why it happened what the
f is junk DNA
so junk DNA are sections of your genetic
code that have no information
which to me
in the Perfection of this human body the
complexity of this human body there's no
room for junk
right so it's just if you're programming
something and there's certain code that
you don't need anymore you turn it off
so at the time if we feel that there was
an edit who edited us I think you have
some theories there right
there was also junk and junk wasn't
added it it seems like there's the troll
sections of our DNA which we don't know
what they do because they're turned off
that are literally off so it's as if you
had a line of computer code and somebody
took a portion of it and censored it and
how can you see the difference between
deleted and censored uh because it's
still there is there so lecture there's
still structure yeah it's structure it's
yeah what's the difference between DNA
that you can see versus the junk DNA
that is empty essentially what does it
look like tangibly so it is encoded
right so there's there's letters that uh
there's four letters a b c t that make
up your genetic code and there's many
many combinations right each each gene
is thousands of letters long yeah right
and then so sometimes there's a c
instead of a t and now that Gene doesn't
do its job properly in a certain
location so there's no code in the junk
it's it's literal junk but how do you
see the code how do you even see a code
uh so that's sequencing so now we're
getting into when so I take your saliva
which I did yeah right and I extract
your DNA from the saliva there's a tool
that does that and we then put that DNA
into a sequencing machine which
literally knows how to read the code on
every chromosome and every so that
that's how it's literally red right by
the sequencing machine okay Illumina is
the biggest company that does that most
companies use alumina uh and when you're
sequencing it this section can't be read
there's nothing to read there's no code
so and and again
if there's nothing in this body that
isn't purposeful yeah right there's
nothing that isn't purposeful and
something as precious and you know a
fundamental foundational sorry as our
genetic code right having space spaces
like empty spaces
there's there's a purpose there and the
purpose is either it used to exist and
it was turned off yeah
or we don't know how to turn it on right
well as you know from our friend Kaya
part of her book the Sofia code is about
verbal initiations that activate dormant
DNA and that makes sense to me because
we talk about elevating Consciousness
we don't understand the science like the
Practical mechanism of what happens what
if you elevate Consciousness which means
you're now sending and receiving what
you couldn't send and received before
that means that those antennas or
whatever those things are are now
activated you didn't have access to them
prior to that so that could be that
maybe there's certain section our DNA
turn off to prevent us from accessing a
certain level of Consciousness that we
can fight and turn on I've experienced
this you've taught we've talked to you
about this you've experienced this in
the last two years I've experienced more
of this in the rest of my life combined
you know there's there's shifts
happening right now that if you're on
the right path you're going to
experience it for sure yeah uh and it's
there so it'd be interesting to see you
know I'm going to do this now now that
you said this I'm going to keep working
on elevating my Consciousness and I'm
going to re-sequence my ID and a to see
if something's changed that didn't exist
before Oh my God or can you see what
percentage of your body has active DNA
versus unread is there
right because if you're you're reading
some but some doesn't read so if you
gave a if you had a sample Can it can
can it evaluate a ratio
so every cell in your body is has DNA in
it so every single cell has active DNA
there's very little junk DNA it's micro
and there's little fragments here and
there that are junk still some junk in
there um all right you have a book okay
what's the book called so the book is
called the DNA way
and early on in this journey you know
when we built the company we were still
a research company at the time biotech
is a weird place to be because you learn
and you don't even know why you're
learning it like what is what is the
product going to be it doesn't even
matter we're just researching and that's
where we were and so I realized as I was
doing this that we needed to normalize
DNA as a tool people don't even know
that it has to be part of your health
toolkit if you don't understand your
foundational code how do you make every
other decision you're going to trial and
error one size fit all things until they
work
and so
um I found I was recommended this book
agent who represents A.D best-selling
medical type authors and he said I love
your story you need to write a book I
agree with you and then he came back to
me after paying him for four or five
months and he said you got rejected by
every single publisher that exists
because you're not a doctor
and I said well I told you up front that
I'm not a doctor and I told you up front
that what I'm trying to fix is the
Health Care system and it takes somebody
from the outside to see what's what what
the blinders on what everybody can't see
right he said I'm sorry this isn't
working so I said give me the list of
who rejected us right and I said thank
you you know here's your check thank you
for your time I'll deal with this myself
so I I found of that list of Publishers
somebody who represented a few authors
that I like that I enjoy including Mindy
by the way right Mindy Pals uh and I
called them
and within three days I had a book deal
yeah and because they didn't I mean what
we do is so impactful but him as a guy
that represents 80 doctors thinks like
the doctors know he himself couldn't get
out of that medical thinking right like
so anyways so the the the intention was
the purpose of this book is for me to go
through my personal genome and show how
easy it is to use these tools and change
your life I've changed my life I've gone
from a 38 year old that was 43
biologically to a 43 year old that is 33
biologically
I'm the best shape of my life mentally
physically in every way even spiritually
my ability to connect is beyond what
it's ever been right uh and so I wanted
to share that with everybody because
whether you have a test or not there's
things to learn in terms of how does the
science work what can you do there's
things that you'll start to Clue Into
and you'll see the world differently
you'll see people differently because
you'll understand how your body actually
works gosh if you're really
a good friend and you're changing lives
and I'm so grateful that we're friends
and that we're sharing this information
you're sharing this information I'm just
like sitting here it's a pleasure I mean
I learn I learn just as much from you as
you as we as you say you're learning
today I'm going to tell you something
your interview with Billy Carson
is the only podcast that I listen to in
my life from beginning to end without
shutting it off for pausing
love it thank you yes and I've heard him
on other podcasts you're the way you
navigated your questions like you are
brilliant and it's we have to say that
that I've never done that ever with any
podcast it was um it was awesome
that's very very nice of you to say
Billy is a fascinating guy with um just
like you very very intelligent retains a
lot of information and is
um another person that's leading the way
um forward just like you are so
um but thank you Billy's great you're
great the show's so fun it's my guilty
pleasure
let's talk to people I love
amazing all right thanks Kashif thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the Subscribe button